welcome sir now you are what what I've
I've just I just met you I know who you
are for a long time but I just
physically am in your presence you're an
ambiguous race I can't figure out are
you Mexican are you white are you Middle
Eastern or are you a trans I don't know
I am uh I am trans Caucasian Are You
full white yeah I'm Irish German and
English what so I'm just kind of like
the trio of the whitest [ __ ] possible
you are the Empire I am the I am I am I
am what Hitler was like yep yeah dude
but you can there's a vibe to you why
I'm like you could also be Latino you're
gonna be a sneaky Latina a lot because
my wife's Mexican okay my kids are
Mexican right and
um a lot of people recently have been
disappointed to find out I was white
yeah a lot of rappers once they find out
I'm white they're like yo
but your wife and I'm like what do you
want from me yeah you don't think a
white guy can [ __ ] get a hot Latin
woman
dude my wife's Puerto Rican that's what
I mean yeah bro but I don't look Latino
at all so you're you're you're certainly
white like it's very clear to me that
like at least my girl she knew she was
going in white your girl could have been
like I thought he was Mexican but now
unfortunately too late it's too late but
it's too late because you're too late
you already dropped that Empire the
Empire day yeah that's what it is it's a
good dick